الان الحديث ابرز الاحداث في العراق لعام
20 22 تنضم الينا من بغداد زميلتنا زينب
المشاط زينب اهلا بك من العواصف الترابيه
الى كاس خليجي 25 وشعار سنه اكو سؤال
صبايا ههه
[ضحك]
اتمنى لكم انها تحققون المزيد من النجاحات
في السنه القادمه بالنسبه الي وعلى الصعيد
الشخصي انا سعيده جدا
شو كله كادر جديد يعني منك وجر
خلص خلص اليوم فش تواصل كملي كملي
تمام طبعا خلال 2022 شهداء العراق العديد
من العواصف الترابيه والتغيرات البيئيه
والمناخيه ايضا شهدت الكثير من المناطق في
العراق جفاف لكن هذا الجفاف همم
نتحدث عنه من الجانب الايجابي انه كان
هناك دعم كبير من السائحين الاجانب والعرب
الذين زاروا العراق خلال هذه الفتره ودعم
المناطق المعرضه لجفاف مثل الاهوار اطلقها
هاشتاج تصدر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي انقذ
الاهوار من الجفاف هذا الدعم ايجابي
بالنسبه للعراقيين ايضا همم
ذهب العراق اكثر من 200 فنان مسرحي عربي
خلال فعاليات مهرجان المسرح الدولي الثالث
وقدم العراق حوالي 19 عمل مسرح هذا ما يدل
على انا المسرح في العراق ينبض بالحياه
اضافه الى هذا ان العراق صدر العديد من
الكتب والثقافه والادب من خلال المثقفين
والكتاب العراقيين وكذلك دول نشر العراقيه
وهذا ما لاحظناه في فعاليات همم معرض
العراق الدولي للكتاب
واختتم العراق عامه 2022 و ايهنطلق ايضا
في عام 2023 بفعاليات كاس الخليج بدورته
الخامسه والعشرين التي ستقام في البصره
وهذا هذه فعاليه تعد مهمه جدا بالعراق
لانفتاحها على دول الخليج مره اخرى وعودته
الدول العربيه كل عام وانت بالف خير